Accord. Off we go. Well, your zoom call. Um, number of questions submitted. So let's get started.
Nothing really new on the member site, except we have a new course.
Um, this chronic disease and autoimmune course right here. Most aptly
pertains to cancer because I have said over or over a decade that I think cancer has
autoimmune components to it. So that can be beneficial. Secondly, that just because we have a
disease like cancer doesn't mean that we don't have other cold morbidities that quite possibly
could have led to our cancer or at least participated in the precipitation of the disease. So
to study other things, especially autoimmune conditions seems relevant. Um, so if you have some
time to kill, you could stomach listening to me. There's a whole bunch of new videos in that course.
Okay. So first question along one follow up to last week.
Shoulder issue wrote to rotator cuff. Got a MRI and I'm prediseled last week.
Tuesday, uh, 12 day, 40 milligram per day, taper, four days before the scan last
Tuesday. Sorry, every time that beeps. I think you guys hear that beep. That's somebody trying to get
it. Um, they did a cervical and a cervical CT scan, I think in a lot of degeneration C5, C6.
Results showed more degeneration and nerve issues, really now rotator cuff. C6 affects the neck,
arm, thumb. So you want to understand the nerve pathways. If you make a, like a okay side with
your hand, like if you're making it okay side, if you did it with your, um, with your left hand,
it looks like the number six. So you got the other, it goes up and you got the okay sign. That's how you
remember. That's your C6 nerve, it actually affects half of your longest finger and then all of
your pointer finger and your thumb and up the lateral side. So if you're standing in, you know,
in a, um, anatomical position, it's the lateral side, um, the radial side of your arm.
Uh, possible issues came up with vertebra bodies, bone marrow, multilevel scattered vertebral
stir, hyper sensitivities with corresponding T1 hyposets, to hypo intensities, most pronounced
at C5 with T2 stir, hyper intensity and metral epidural space measuring 10 millimeters in
cranial coddle, dimension and more subtle T2 stir, hyper intensity and the ventral epidural
space behind the C6 vertebral body. Suspicious for epidural spread of tumor, no compression fractions.
So let's back up here just a little bit. So if you do a CT scan or an MRI, you have a lot of
degeneration. You could have degeneration. So just about everybody, as we age, we have degenerative
dysdysses. Um, that is a degenerative arthritis or used to be called wear and tear arthritis.
That's common. It's almost in, in everybody. That's how we're, well, it used to be six two
now. I'm six one. Um, you know, you lose height of your disc that's caused a lot. That's called
loss of inhibition of your disc space. Um, that's normal. So this degeneration is normal. A degenerative
disc is not pathological. Beauty, that's not from pathological disease like cancer. So metastasis of
cancer would not cause this. Now I understand. You could have this, plus you could have metastasis
of cancer. So when they're talking about stir, hyper intensities that's talked about possible
increased metabolic activity because of possible metastasis. So when you're, when this is listed,
they're thinking about metastasis. This piece does not have to do with metastasis. This is possible
metastasis. So if you have metastasis to the spine that can cause, um, issues decrease calcium
in the vertebral bodies and you could get some narrowly to the vertebral body without complete
destruction of the vertebral body, destruction of the vertebral body would be pathological.
And that could be, you know, enough on top of this to start to cause
morbidities of, of, you know, pain. So, pain that radiates through pathway, the peripheral
nerve pathway. Um, this person goes on to say there were no compression fractures. So good,
that would be more later stage. Uh, remember, when, when you have metastasis to the bone,
it's elitic, it's great in which means it's breaks down the bone, it's eroding the bone,
body erosion. And then you end up with less of lack of bone density. And if it's weight-barried
bone, you could end up with a compression fracture, it's called pathologic fracture pain.
Okay. So, question is your, um, could, um, uh, trauma having the trauma and previous
predisone, do you think this could be affecting the scan? No, I don't think that would affect the scan.
So I, um, I don't, the, the hyperintensive is what they're concerned with, with possible metastasis.
Schedule to do printuvo in a few weeks, not to sure if that will be any cleaner or not.
Well, there's still debate on that, whether that'll be cleaner, I think that's a good thing to do.
I think it's just more testing would be good. There's zero invasiveness with the preduvo scan.
Uh, I do have slow differential metastatic disease scattered through throughout the vertebra
bodies, but no paid anywhere else. The orthopedic guy said that C5, C6 cause is what's causing the
arm and shoulder pain. Yep. I would agree. Um, doesn't mean that so don't think that just because, uh,
CT scan of your shoulder ruled out rotator cuff, all they're looking for is a tear.
So if they don't see any tear in the rotator cuff, you know, they're, they're instantly
really known to rotator cuff. Well, you can still have, you can still have, um, you know,
muscular strain, ligamentus, sprayed, um, that they won't see on MRI. So don't, you know, doctors
equally make the mistake to that, oh, you have cancer. Oh, we don't see any rotator cuff
um, uh, tear. So it's probably because metastatic disease. And that's what it is. So don't let them
jump to that conclusion completely either. And though you might have some metastasis, some increase
intensity in different areas here, it doesn't, you know, it doesn't mean you don't have a
core ability of a muscle, uh, sprayed or ligamentus strain, uh, flip that around. And that could be
the real issue. So don't give up on treating it from a muscular skeletal point of view.
Why did you expect that my, uh, alpha fetal protein to a marker test will take a while to drop
after surgery? Well, I did, if I said that I didn't, I misspoke. I didn't expect it to,
it's just that's, I've just seen that sometimes it could take, you know, a few weeks for your
tumor workers to drop post surgery. Now, I did a, uh, uh, brief, you know, uh, search on the literature
on any data on this. And I just can't find any studies on when the tumor workers will drop
and, um, post surgery. So, in fact, there's very little on the AFP tumor marker with breast cancer,
it's literally almost most of the research is done, uh, liver cancer. So, um, it's hard to find any
research on this, uh, this stuff. So it's, it's very difficult. It's just through the years of, um,
trying to help people with this. My, what I've noticed is that two workers don't necessarily
drop suddenly post surgery. Um, so that's what I meant to say. Why might other two of
workers rise after surgery? Again, you know, you remember that, you know, two of
workers are just one test and it's not perfect. The only data that you can really find of what
causes two of workers to rise is, is, uh, the use of chemotherapy. And that certainly doesn't happen
every time. You know, we have patients probably on this call that did chemotherapy, that didn't cause
their tumor markers to spike. But I'll get, you know, tell you for sure, over the years, I've seen that
lots of times where people will start chemotherapy. So the tumor markers literally just a little skyrocket.
Some people's body doesn't respond the same way. So all I'm saying is that there's not really any data
that says that it's, uh, bad thing that two of markers are dropping quickly. There's no data
went to where markers will drop and, and how much they will drop after surgery. It's just,
we're just, it's a speculation at this point. Most recent labs show free T3. So, so the person's
talking about this free T3 is a thyroid marker. So that's free T3 is your active thyroid hormone.
Um, so it's at the low end of range 2.0 and my free T4 is high outside of range. Uh, and
my MD said she had never seen such high T, uh, free T4 with low T3 without external supplementation
to drive up the T4. Um, well, I would say that your MD probably doesn't see a lot of thyroid
patients that because this scenario of high of, uh, of low T3 and high free T4 is called the
under conversion effect. So understand your thyroid gland makes over 90% of the hormone that the
thyroid gland spits out is T4, which is not the active form of the thyroid hormone.
The active form is T3 and it's free T3. Understand that 90% of the, the, um, the T4,
that, and 10% T3 that's spitting out by the thyroid gland is also protein bound. It's not even either one
of them are in the active form yet. And then T4 is converted by an enzyme called 5dehyde noase.
Um, in the liver and in the gut to become bound T3. And then the protitis shed and you have
active form of T3. So when a person has high free T4 and low free T3, that means they're not
converting T4 to T3 adequately. That is, that is usually the possibilities of that, that's,
again called under conversion effect. It's not converting T4 to T3 and it's usually because
a person has Hashimoto's and they may actually be attacking the 5dehyde noase
enzyme that converts T4 to T3. Number two, they could have gut or liver issues. So they're not
producing that enzyme and they're not getting the conversion. So you have to look at, uh, antibodies
in the gut food antibodies, typically, that would cause that and lead to lead, lead, lead,
you got other things too. So that's really, this is called under conversion effect. It's very common
with Hashimoto's. I don't know, I don't remember who asked this question, but you should make sure
that you are getting TPO antibodies and viral globulin antibodies tested as well because
pretty much guaranteed that if you don't know what already, you have Hashimoto's disease. So
that is an autoimmune thyroid. She wanted me to check iron content of all my supplements.
But I don't see anything significant there. Does this look wacky to you as well? Any ideas for
cause? So under conversion has caused from a person beat in Hashimoto's and they have an attack on
the 5dehyde noase enzyme or they don't have the conversion going out of their liver or in their gut
because of liver and gut issues. Very common with Hashimoto's. Um, hey, you know, you could learn all
about this in this course right here, this chronic disease. I have the module six oldest module is
all about Hashimoto's more than you ever to know. For SEACT liquid concentrate protocol, I understand to
use one tablespooned hot water, sift over 15 minutes. I usually use eight ounces of water. What if I use
room temperature water? Also, one of the consequences of drinking it all at once, especially if I forget
to sip it over 15 minutes or I'm in a hurry. Yeah, this is a hard one because that was just that was
just a recommended protocol that that was always recommended for SEACT and it was typically you sip it
over 15 to 30 minutes, you make a tee out of it. Is there benefit to that? Don't know. I don't really know.
I, you know, I've had patients over the years that they mixed it in their smoothies. It's like
I don't think they had any ill consequences. I mean, I don't think it, you know, didn't work any last,
you know, it's, they're just herbs and just because they were mixed in a tee at one point in time,
doesn't mean you have to do it that same way all the time. You know, it's like the old story of,
you know, the lady who cuts off the end of the rose before she puts it in the pan, before she puts
it in the oven and her husband said, why do you do that? She said, well, because mom always did it.
We'll call her and ask her. She called her mom and said, why do you always cut the end off the rose
before you put it in the pan before you put it in the oven? She said, I don't know, grandma used to
always do that. So she called grandma, why do you always cut the end off the rose before you put it in the
pan before you put it in the oven? Grandma said, because the pan was too small. So sometimes there's
that always a good reason for why it's done. I just try to logically think through it and I don't
think that doing it the way you're doing it is necessarily going to cause any different effects of it.
Sometimes there's a physiological reason for it and I could kind of rationalize through that
and some of these things and sometimes I can't figure out any physiological difference. Certainly
taking any nutrients over a longer period of time, you're going to have maybe better absorption of it.
And if you take a nutrient and break it down into three doses over the day,
you know, we've talked about the every nutrient in your body has a half-life,
meaning that if I take everything, you know, it will take at six o'clock in the morning,
there's good chance at six o'clock at night. I don't have a whole lot of that nutrient circulating
in the web bloodstream. So spreading out the dosage definitely has physiological benefit. I don't
sipping it over 15 minutes versus opening it down as much. I've been taking opti-adrenal,
this is a Dr. Brimhall supplement, for a number of years, I'm wondering if I know I shouldn't
needed anymore. What product does clinic have? That's comparable to opti-adrenal.
Well, opti-adrenal is kind of like a multi. It's got a lot of some adaptogens in it for
the adrenal gland. It's got some b-vitamins in it and such. The problem with like a multi-supplement
that has a ton of stuff in it is that it has a lot less of everything in it because you only have
the same size pill, the put stuff in it, right? So it's definitely as it's it's typically used
as an adaptogen to help support adrenal gland and it's got the b-vitamins in it to help support
adrenal gland. It's a good supplement. I wouldn't address. I wouldn't use the opti-thyroid
product that they have at the opti-adrenal. It's a good supplement. I don't think there's any reason
why you don't have to change it unless you're like just trying to cut out on supplements.
But like the adaptogens that we have, there's more of them in because there's only like some of them
have three, some of them have five nutrients, specific herbs in the hill. So you're going to have
a greater concentration versus having 40 things in a pill. You're going to have a much lesser
concentration as well. But if you're doing well with it, I wouldn't say to change it. I think it's
I think it's a good product. I recently stumbled upon a test called HTMA Air Tissue
Mineral Analysis. What are your thoughts on this test? It would you recommend it.
So if it's a here analysis test, you take a clip of your hair. So I'm discussing it because I don't
let this test it. So just by the name of it, I'm sure that it's a clip of your hair and you're
setting it in for mineral analysis instead of for having metal analysis. I would say it's not a
good test for mineral analysis. And hair analysis is not the best test for heavy metal analysis either.
But there isn't a lot of other good tests for heavy metal analysis. So there is a urine test
for heavy metal analysis, but you're taking a strong key later, like the MSA,
kind of it over abundance to pull it out of the tissues to dump what you can into the urine,
so then you're measuring it. And I think that's a very poor test because you can make a person
really sick with that test. So I think hair analysis is the best option that exists for heavy metal
testing. If you want to really assess mineral analysis in your body, you really have to do an
interest cellular nutritional tests. I forgot to name that test off my head because I don't
ever use that test. Hair analysis video test, I'd say no, do not use that. It's not going to be
accurate at all. Second part of the question, I've had a Dutch test. So a Dutch test test is a
dried urine analysis test for four bones. And your cheeks walk test. I'm wondering if this test would
offer additional benefits. I'd say no, don't do that test. It's not other tests that can offer
benefits. I get out of the courses if I were you and look at what you're trying to analyze and the
information that you're trying to gain. As you go through the courses, something might spark your
attention, like, oh my gosh, I should do this microtox test because I was exposed to mold of so
much in my life. And maybe that's is kind of a hidden issue. Well then, so that's what other
reasons why I created these courses is for you guys to be able to study on your own to go, wow,
this could be a possible solution for myself too. So you know, there you have free access to all those
courses. You had recommended cleansing for Tim three per day based on the last cheek swab. Additionally,
just gave it to him one per meal along with other supplements gave him diarrhea. So now we're giving
separated from meals. Shouldn't it be separate? You don't have to take that separate, but
you know, I think about the physiology of it probably might work better separated. So remember,
the cleanse eye is the oxygenated magnesium. So cleanse eye, though it does have asterzyme in it,
which all the US enzyme products have asterzyme in it, even though the asterzyme, which is their
proprietary enzyme, is not really, you're not taking the product for the asterzyme. You know,
it's just helping the product work better and the active ingredient work better. The active
ingredient in cleanse eye is the oxygenated magnesium. And I spoke about this a few Zoom calls
ago that the Harvard scientist who has the patents on oxygenated magnesium, the only company that uses
his full proprietary utilization of his patents is the US enzyme. So there's other oxygenated
magnesiums out there, but they're not using his full patent in the formula, which they're not
getting the benefits. And so what's the purpose of oxygenated magnesium is that you're, it will kill
pathogens in your gut and it has the potential of killing tumors in your gut as well. So that's what
trusted 4G of last time. So maybe it might be better to take that on an empty stomach.
He's got three different enzymes, one to help digest food, one to eat on the tumor,
and now this cleanse eye that we don't know what it's for. So it doesn't seem to do
well with enzymes. It doesn't do well with enzymes. Probably because
so it defines on what on well. And so it's giving it more gas and stomach aches times. It's probably
because it is doing well. So usually when a person says I don't do well with enzymes, even if they
don't have any type of cancer whatsoever, it's a sign that they need more enzymes. So that's almost
100% of the time. Certainly with a cancer patient, if they're getting more symptoms by taking the
enzymes, it's in my opinion, it's really because the enzymes are actually working to break down the tumor.
And that's exactly what we want to do. So we want to try to get up to dose with those.
Now that I've done with seven weeks of radiation and four rounds of light chemo or my squamous cell
counselor cancer, one of the best things I could do to help clean up my system would stimulate normal
saliva production. Well, the radiation really does a job on your parod and gland. And that is hard
for saliva production. There are some rotted glandular products out there, one by Bionics research.
You'd like to call it in because Bionics is one of the companies that contacted us so they don't
allow any internet sales anymore. So they don't allow their products to be viewed by anybody online.
So you don't have to call in. We can still sell them but we can't show them
on our store any longer.
So just know that you can call it in. The protted product might be good for you. It might be good to do
a cheek swab again too. Lots of eucostyle, they expect to dry mouth and still they need to be a feeding
tube just on a speech there. Okay, good idea to do it maybe in cheek swab. I don't know. Okay,
just FYI was discussing Pradova with my empty and she mentioned they could do less than full body.
Yes, they can. You don't have to do a full body. You can do partial whatever you're looking for.
With press cancer for about a thousand dollars. Yeah, I think they even post their prices online
or at least you could call them. So that's a decent price. I think if you go if you went and
had to pay out of pocket just for an MRI, they could be at least 20 by cutter bucks. So
and no MRIs, our full body was only sectional. I'm on a low carb diet, 20 to 30 grams a day,
is grass-fed butter to help substitute for little carbs. Okay, what fat other than
butter for a long term to get enough calories? I am very slim already.
So if you know if cancer is being driven by dairy, can you have a little butter?
Yes, I think you can have a little butter. You don't have to be that strict on your diet,
but everybody's definition of a little butter is different. My grandson will take a stick of butter
and take a bite out of it. But you can put a lot of butter on a piece of bread too. So it's just
you know, just having that balance. Certainly eating grass-fed butter has other health benefits.
It is a good fact. So that's you know, that you know something to think about. It's better than
the margin or these crappy garbage fats. So eating some grass-fed butter, I would say yes,
you could eat grass-fed butter. As far as getting calories, you want to be you know,
um if you're losing weight, then you have to kind of flip the switch to you have to get calories.
You can't be in a state of cakexia where you're losing two to three pounds a week. That's just very
unhealthy. So you have to think about doing some getting back to some more complex carbohydrates.
Now that will throw off your grams per day of your low-carb diet, but you have to you can't
be can't keep losing weight if that's your issue. Recently read an article about heat shock proteins
and cold shock proteins produced by cold or heat therapies on both of these beneficial
for cancer patients. I know that infrared sonas are good. They didn't create heat shock proteins.
Um, Megan has suggested I could do mistletoe therapy. Okay, that's a different question.
So yeah, there's just not a lot of research out there to be honest, um, about, you know, hot and cold
therapies for cancer patients. Matter of fact, you won't get a research paper. You won't get a
research grant or you will not get a research. In order to research, you have to get this
number and apply for it if you're doing human research. So, um, and then to get it published,
you know, that's a whole other story. And if you're not tied it in with, you know, using cold
therapy with cancer patients, along with chemotherapy, you're not tied in the chemotherapy,
you're not even getting PRP. That's called that's the approval process for doing research.
Is it involved with the research project about 15 years ago and getting a PRP was just really,
really difficult to get. There wasn't on cancer or something else, but, um, so I don't know if there's
a lot of research out there for these kind of things. These not the US. There's, there is some data
with infrared sonas that infrared heated and using heat on breast cancer, but not a lot of other
cancers. So, um, but I do, you know, there's anecdotal evidence that using both cold and hot therapy
can be beneficial for cancer patients. And I really think when cold therapy is beneficial,
not that it kills cancer, unless you're doing isolated cryotherapy on cancer. We're talking
about what you could do with cold, like cold bath therapies. It helps decrease inflammation.
So, that's a huge benefit for anybody. I think our kids are gone.
Megan has suggested I should better, uh, I could benefit from missile therapy in your opinion.
Is this a good therapy and what type of cancer patients can benefit from this?
Well, uh, any hard cancer patients can benefit that I mean that blood cancer patients.
Um, uh, so you have a physical tumor. They can benefit from missile cell therapy.
Missile therapy is a stimulant, is a immune stimulant. Uh, you could do IV missile cell therapy,
or you could do missile therapy that you do at home. It's an injectable, you inject it into your
belly and you get this reaction. They get, it's basically an immune reaction. Anybody can benefit from it.
Um, so I would have hesitated about tried it and you're kind of stuck with care for the client.
I need to add notes on my C5C6 issues for the earlier question. The C5C6 and C6 redemonstrated mild
spinal canal stavosis with deformed spinal cord with marginal cerebral spinal fluid. Surrounded the
cord plus severe right and right and moderate to severe left. Uh, neuroframal um, uh, narrowing. So
your, your spinal foreamid is where the nerve root comes out on both the left and right side
between the two vertebrae and it can become narrowed and causing impingement for many reasons.
It can be arthritis into the spinal frame and it can be loss of disc
inhibition, like I mentioned. So you have a decrease in disc height. Therefore the
parameter is going to be impinged. Uh, you can have a disc bulge into the uh, uh, the frame
and that can cause impingement. Um, uh, so stenosis just means impingement. So, um,
use, stenosis is an old word used. Usually at least used to be used from
bony impingement from arthritis, but it's not how we use that same way.
Impingement of the bilateral C-sector root secondary to severe
desiccation. So, desiccation is loss of bone density, moderate to severe disc osteophyte
complex. So, osteophyte, fight is a spur of a bone. So, disc, severe disc osteophyte. So,
uh, osteophyte is not from a disc, but um, osteophyte complex has to do with, so they say disc,
osteophyte complex is the loss of, uh, it's a disc bulge with spur, bony spur formation.
That's arthritis. So, that's what a degenerative disc disease is. That's what they're probably
talking about with disc there and a degenerative arthritis. That's the osteophyte complex is.
Myel ligamentum flavum ligamentum flavum runs straight down, uh,
in front of the spinal cord, right down the, um, center of the, uh,
frame and make them all the way down here vertically. Hypertrophic calcification. So,
you've got increased calcification, severe bilateral, uh, uncov, uh,
uncle vertebral joint. So, your uncle vertebral joint is your lateral joints of that form,
your joints that you, when you bend from side to side, hypertrophy and mild bilateral fat
facet. Um, so this is your facet joints. You have arthritis or your facet joints.
And an MRI with contrast and the possible tumor issue came up as a possibility and stated contrast
to confirm. So, everything that we talked about here has to do with degenerative arthritis,
uh, degenerative disc disease. This is not pathological, the sense of cause from,
from cancer. This has to do with post injury wear and tear. Um, this is not even caused from a,
uh, yeah, from a inflammatory arthritis like, um, like rheumatoid or something like that. These,
this is degenerative arthritis. So, degenerative arthritis is evident in a person post injury.
Let's say they did a lot of work lifting and with their back, maybe they had an injury in college.
And now it's just the degeneration starting to, um, back and forth.
What I need is your opinion or suggestions. They will want the contrast or CT contrast to
confirm to know if the tumor is spread. So again, we could have something going on with the cancer
underlining this as well. And I think you should rule that out. I'm not sure if vertebral will be
any clear. Yeah, I'm not positive either. You got that schedule. I think I would keep that schedule
and do that. A PET scan might be helpful. You might ask them about that getting a PET scan.
Let's see what that would show about a crossroads and what to do. It's taper a predisode.
I am five days away from finishing the milk pain yet. Okay, that's good.
Um, I would keep running the rife programs for pain, keep running the accelerated keeling program
on the rife that we talked about last week. I'd be using some CBD lotion too. I would
and the skin that can be beneficial. I'd be up in my curriculum in big time,
up in my postwellia and other intents, laboratory, labinoids and stuff. I'd up that big time.
Um, uh, concerned about the radiologist saying possible tuber spread. I mean, anything is possible.
It's possible, you know, just given your history that that's there or could be just solely because
a muscular skeleton. Should the biotoxin binder be taken with food or not?
Um, you know, some of your nutrition, uh, I'll be honest with you. I'm not very good
at trying to separate out with my personal supplements with food or not. I'm not very good at
taking my personal supplements because I get so busy. I forget. So, so that's not a good thing to admit
to all your people, but you guys, some of you are really good at taking your things and I don't
typically, you know, accept what it's really important to all people to, to take things with food
or without food, unless it's really important. A lot of your nutrition are food products,
or saying they're whole food in nature. So, taking them with food really doesn't make any
difference and it can actually be better. Something's taken with food can help with your stomach and
even things that maybe should be taken on empty stomach. For a lot of people that are really ill,
it hurts their stomach if they get on empty stomach. So, taking it with their food can help with
stomach upset and, you know, if their stomach gets upset when they take their stuff on an empty stomach,
they just won't take it. So, um, the binders probably better taken away from food. So, I would say,
if you're really good at it, I would take the biotoxin binder away from food.
Um, some things like I tell you, if you're, if I have you on a digestive enzyme for food,
you take it with your meal, you certainly take HCl with a meal, not on an empty stomach.
And some things I like, I have you on an enzyme therapy, I say you have to take this on an empty stomach.
There's just a must now, no firmling things.
Is seven weeks post-op, uh, okay for a lymphatic massage doc doesn't want it to push fluid out of
the scars and drainage holes to reopen with them. I just have paper tape over my incisions or scars.
I don't think there's a problem with it as long as you have a trained massage therapist who is
certified in lymphatic massage and that you, I personally would have them stay away from
your wounds. I would agree you don't want to break things open.
We had a patient who wants that and really, really botched surgery, horribly botched surgery,
and it was the surgeon's fault. But, you know, I have seen the results of a wound that got opened
post-surgery and just could not heal. So I would just be more careful than not at all back.
Anyone have any experience, information on a couple called EVC-46? I think it has an effective
in a clinical trial as cancer treatment for dogs. So, um, see if that's the same thing when we use the
carry. Yes, we used to carry that. We could only get it from Australia. It's Blushberry.
Blushwood berries tincture is what it is. We started carrying that because I saw a study that
was beneficial for breast cancer. And I just did have enough people and I should really notice
what, if I was happy with it, I'm not. And then with COVID, we couldn't get it anymore. So they
weren't shipping to the day it states through the years of COVID, so we ended up taking it off our store.
But it's just an herb that you can only get over in Australia. It's called Blushwood berry tincture.
If you, I believe I'm looking, I just Google it. I think you can order it online. So, so they
must be back in business. They were just closed to carry and hold them. All right. I'll say good
night to all of you. Hopefully you're getting better weather. And, um, just know that I prayed for you all.
Please get out of the courses and you have questions about it. You can schedule a time with me to
take out any tests. Thank you very much. Bye-bye.